which man wish also known as a warlock
you could say it was popular in 1930 but
better witches don't go out of style
because witches his [ __ ] the Prince
of Darkness Beelzebub Satan the devil
who's the most badass of all the beasts
there's gotta be sentence go to the moon
[ __ ]
Matt Damon stunt double from Martian
this was famous in the 60s because the
60s is when we went to the moon John F
Kennedy spearheaded the NASA effort and
I was born in the 60s 69
sir Arthur Fonzarelli played by Henry
Winkler in the seven he could fix broken
machinery with a little Henry Winkler
was voted sexiest man alive in 1978
because of what happy gains Hey it's
really exhausting doing pay way I've
noticed he's got three gears there's the
weird giggle got kids con really really
proud of this thing he's got a thing no
one could even touch it best in the
world and then he's got the other thing
where he's like where have you gone
pivot ninja impossible to detect
he hides in the shadows he is one with
the surroundings I'm a ninja Wibbly will
pop up you know what I'm missing are
those disgusting teeth does anybody have
some gross teeth
it would really put the finishing touch
on this costume are those used
let's make shagadelic sex in my bed so
I've never seen the show Jersey Shore
but I think they kind of like this go
down to the beach shun ashore I'm gonna
go get some drinks and make love the
ladies in the Smoky get over here I know
Snookie hailey